what's up fellow geeks this is the soul
hackers 2 collectors edition and we got
it in english so let's just open it up
and see what we have inside so let's
remove this first
get out the way
next thing the openings on the back
like that
okay
so obviously the first thing we have is
the soul hackers game with the pre-order
bonus dlc inside that's for us
so next up is the book for solace 2.
there's a bunch of art and stuff inside
unfortunately everything's japanese so
if you're into that you know this is for
you
next up is the ost which consists of
three cds and 30 songs so probably 10
songs per cd and we'll open up the main
game to see what's inside later on as
well
okay
so let's open this up
wow okay
so with this little insert down here
doesn't really say much but basically
just details the composers of the ost
and these are how the cds look like
here we are
and to open up this one let's see what's
inside as well
so yeah this is the main game we're
going to open up and see what's inside
and honestly there is
there's nothing much it's just the game
and the dlc that we got and obviously we
can't show that for you know
obvious reasons
and of course the peace teller distance
of the ce edition is a figurine of i
hope
let's open it up
more tape amazing
can i just peel it off
all right
and this i hold there are no noticeable
manufacturing errors no shading errors
you know no spillage of the different
paints and everything so it's a really
well detailed figure so this is the base
pick nothing much going on down here
so let's just put it on
let's put it on
and there we go
yeah that's that's pretty sick
so to cap it off we have the main game
the i o figurine the anniversary book
and the ost
and this is all you're going to get
together with the other dlc codes inside
this edition so if you like these
unboxing videos make sure to follow us
on all of our socials to keep up to date
with what we're doing leave a like and
subscribe to us we have a ton of content
coming your way
this is inio and i'm signing off peace
[Music]
you